as the weather warms up the bees come
out and for some
swarms are spelling danger thank you so
much for joining us tonight at 11
o'clock i'm sasha loftis
firefighters have already responded to
several calls this month the latest
invasion killing a dog in the west
valley
madison kimbrough spoke with some who
live in the neighborhood where this
happened
she joins us live with their reaction
and tips from experts to keep us all
safe
madison yes it was just yesterday that
fire officials arrived
in this neighborhood off of lorenzi
street after a
an infestation of bees occurred a lot of
people were stung and a lot of people
were attacked
and so they were told to stay inside
along with their animals
to bring them inside with them a friend
came into the garage and all of a sudden
he's slapping like crazy on himself and
he said
i got bit i got bit again and then he
started running
and he got bit five times ramona eubanks
has lived in this northwest neighborhood
for over
50 years and she says they have never
had issues with bees
but yesterday they did experts on scene
were rushing everyone to shelter in
place
so he said don't go anywhere don't go
outside
because they're all over they even
chased him down the street
her neighbor just a couple houses down
jim smith had his own encounter
yesterday too
we was going to do some grilling and
then and my
niece was over and she said there's a
bee in the house
and i go out there and then all of a
sudden i'm getting attacked tim samanski
with las vegas fire and rescue explains
why bees react aggressively this way
the stinger has a a sack on it and it
pulls the inside of the bee out it
it kills the bee but that when the sack
comes out it releases an odor
that goes back to the hive that tells
the the colony that they
are under attack las vegas fire and
rescue say that if a hive is present and
an encounter has taken place
in most of the cases bees must be
exterminated and the hive needs to be
removed by a licensed
professional
las vegas fire and rescue has responded
to three bee related incidences within
the past
month and as for this neighborhood the
beehive has yet to be found but fire
officials
and residents are still on high alert
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now